we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p very
interesting voicemail about the criminal
justice system that came in take a
listen to this one
hi david my name is lindsay I live in
Tampa Florida I was listening to your
interview and was just kind of wondering
what the effects on the criminal justice
system will be if all of those low-level
offenders pled not guilty what kind of
effect would it have on I mean the whole
court system from low-level misdemeanors
all the way up to high-level felonies
well what you do a solutely fantastic
question
absolutely fantastic question the
criminal justice system the court system
would grind to a halt if they lost the
benefit of what I call the plea deal
industrial complex where most charges do
not lead to trials and it is something
that I've read sort of extensively about
if you actually were able to get the
resources for a lot of these defendants
and if the sort of economic
circumstances didn't prevent them from
just having to take a plea deal and you
got more not guilty pleas it would grind
the system to a halt in such a an acute
way that there would be no choice but to
reform the system and to change how it
functions but unfortunately it all
benefits from the fact that a lot of
defendants don't have the financial
resources to do it and that for other
reasons it's also extraordinarily
difficult but very very good question
we've got a tremendous bonus show for
you today we will talk about a house
democratic investigation into voter
suppression in Florida we've been
calling for this since the midterm
election and it is actually starting up
the citizenship question has been
blocked from the 2020 census that's good
news and we will talk about it and
lastly uber has been found not
criminally liable in the death of the
woman who was hit by a self-driving car
which we
reported on extensively up until this
point that is according to a prosecutor
and we will talk about all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
speak to you then